do you think that house targaryen
wants for strength
if someone offered you more dragons
would you not take them
do you have dragons to offer
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about the third episode of house of the
dragon the one where if you haven't read
a head like i have you might start to
wonder if any of this had to happen
things get interesting as we jump
forward in time and welcome another
member to the family of house targaryen
other prominent westerosi players close
to the king start to get some ideas and
all the king wants to do is hunt and not
have so many problems with his daughter
who he thinks is a contrarian that is
not taking her role as his heir
seriously she senses that he might be
the only one that wants that and resists
attempts to have her marry as a way to
reinforce her position as the future
leader of the seven kingdoms i'll be
getting into all of what happened but do
have to warn you about spoilers if you
haven't watched a second of his name yet
then this video won't be for you and
with that out of the way let's get into
it
last week we jumped ahead six months and
this week we've gone forward three years
beceres announced he would marry allison
at the end of episode two and now they
have a son that's celebrating his second
birthday you see that there are murmurs
about him naming baby aegon his heir now
that his infancy is behind him that's
where the title of the episode comes
from he would be the second aegon to
rule the realm if he ascends to the iron
throne with the first being the
conqueror that started all this off the
king seems more than happy to just
celebrate his son's day but he gets
interrupted by his current master of
ships a persistent thailand lannister
who wants to discuss the stepstones i
probably don't need to remind many
people that the lannister family plays
an important role in game of thrones
however if you're new to this world they
are a powerful family and i'm sure we'll
learn a lot more about them as the
season goes on thailand took over the
role after corliss bounced out of king's
landing and in his following the king
around we get a general idea that things
haven't been going well and that the
crown is still not interested in helping
since damon and corliss went off to
start their war without his blessing as
viserys gets more annoyed with thailand
you see that he's also upset that rinera
isn't there she's out in the godswood
reading and having a musician play the
same song for her over and over allison
comes out to try to get her to come on
the hunt with her father it's clear that
their friendship is a lot different than
the last time we saw them here and based
on this exchange it seems like renera
hasn't gotten over the fact that she
married her father and that she doesn't
keep that a secret it seems like alison
might be trying to make an effort to
make things better but in the end after
we see that she's the more powerful of
the two as the queen she essentially
orders renera to join them in their
coach viserys is still loving the dad
life and brings up that soon it will be
raniera's turn to make some babies of
her own and make him a grandsire alison
who looks like she's about to give birth
to their second child at any second
tries to tell her pregnancy isn't so bad
when she isn't interested in that her
father tries to get her excited to ride
with him during the hunt and again she's
not interested they have a brief back
and forth and when he pushes her to take
up her duties as the princess she says
no one's here for me and this is
something that will come up a couple of
times throughout the episode
when he arrives at the hunt you get to
sense that this is what his reign is all
about tourneys hunts and lots of feasts
which i suppose is fitting for a
peacetime king when they arrive you see
some new characters you see lionel
strong his master of laws with his two
sons harwin aka breakbones and larris
aka the clubfoot you also see tylan
lannister again and this time with his
twin brother jason who was played by the
same actor rather than twins you also
see otto's big brother hobert for the
second time this episode you can't
forget that otto also has that second
sun energy even though he's pretty
important as the hand in king's landing
and it's fairly obvious that hobert
wants to see aegon replace renera as the
heir in case it's not obvious alison is
a hightower so having her son and line
take over would be great for his family
and everyone in old town this is all
important and it's something that i'll
come back around to towards the end in
the last episode we saw that no one at
court was really warming up to the fact
that she is the king's choice and in
this episode three years later we see
her sort of wandering around looking
like she has no place there's talk from
the ladies from house's lannister and
red wine that the king should intervene
in the stepstones and she reminds them
that it's not the crown that's at war
she also mentions that she hasn't talked
to damon for years which leads us to
believe that the last time they saw each
other was on that bridge at dragonstone
say what you will about how good
becerras is at being king but it looks
like he throws one hell of a barbecue
there we see jason lannister introduce
himself and he comes on pretty strong to
renera he mentions building a dragon pit
and when she asks why he do that he says
that he'd do anything for his queen or
his lady wife she gets the idea that
he's presenting himself as a potential
suitor and decides to leave it's also
important that he says or my lady wife
because it shows that he doesn't think
she'll end up being the heir now that
aegon is in the picture she goes to her
father to complain and he gets worked up
saying that ever since she came of age
he's been bombarded by proposals he's
tried to discuss it with her but she
hasn't been interested and things start
to get loud when she says she doesn't
want to get married he shouts that even
he isn't above tradition and duty and
makes a scene of arguing with her about
it in front of everyone otto interjects
that there's been a sighting of the
white heart a large deer they call the
king of the kingswood and she takes the
chance to go outside and mount her horse
and take off and sir kristen cole
follows her there's a chase he finally
catches up to her and they have a heart
to heart about their different stations
and how she thinks he's lucky that he
had a choice in how to live his life and
i mean the grass is always greener on
the other side but how about a little
self-awareness from the princess who had
the most decked out reading spot i've
ever seen and another live human being
there to perform her songs on repeat and
that's the thing about this episode and
these people there isn't any they're all
on a scale of being insufferable which i
suppose everyone is depending on your
perspective but these people have power
maybe not as much as they'd like in
their respective positions but real
power based on who they are and i
brought this up in my video last week
when they don't get what they want there
will be consequences and it's usually
other people who pay the price and
speaking of other people doing things
for you there's a massive group of
people coordinating this hunt for the
king and he gets some word on the white
heart and some droppings to examine this
gets auto pumped up because he sees a
way in and says that this might be
important if the gods were to decide to
show their favor it would all be
conveniently pointing to his grandson
needing to become the king of the realm
jason lannister presents the now
drinking king with a spear those drinks
bring out a different side of viserys
when jason again brings up the idea of
renera being passed over the king takes
offense it's clear there's interest in
replacing her but vasara seems to be
sticking with his decision he proclaims
that he didn't name his daughter his
heir on a whim and all the lords of the
kingdom would do well to remember that
when he talks to otto later about
jason's pride having pride and echoing
what ronera said about him earlier his
hand responds that she'll do as you
command and this opens up the door for
the king to say that he actually wants
her to be happy in another attempt to
position his two-year-old grandson to be
the heir he suggests that maybe they
should betray them to each other and
that leads becerras to say he came there
for the hunt not all of this politicking
which you can see is definitely driving
him a little bit nuts he lets his
frustration show again when he's talking
to lionel when he says find targaryen
king i am powerless over my known
daughter of seven and ten his master of
laws brings up the problems that the
very popular king jiharis had with his
own daughters saying that this is just
tradition and i don't want to go down
that rabbit hole here but i'll just
mention that one of the good king's
daughters ended up a sex worker in lease
and the king decided just to leave her
there he also offers up his opinion on
what the king should do and to
becerras's surprise he's not suggesting
his own son but instead he suggests that
he should marry manira to the sea snakes
and his reasoning is still the same as
when he told the king to marry his
sister laina renera is still hiding out
in the woods with kristen and she asked
him if he thinks the realm will ever
accept her as its queen he points out
that they have no choice and then things
get crazy when a wild boar charges him
and he stabs it when it tries to attack
ronira then when it's laying on the
ground and it moves again she stabs it
repeatedly with her dagger which i
suppose shows that she can take care of
things herself when necessary if you're
wondering what all of this is about
obviously there's some chemistry here
and we've seen that continue from the
first episode and you just need to
remember that this is forbidden fruit
the members of the kingsguard take a vow
of celibacy and it's been established
they do it again in this episode that
this is a great position for kristen to
hold since he doesn't come from a strong
family drunken becerras has taken to
standing by the bonfire and his wife
allison goes to talk to him he admits
that he named renera to protect the
realm from daemon she was his only child
she was the realms delight and he named
her out of love and then he gets into
this idea that many of his line were
dragon riders but only a few were
dreamers he had the dream that he told
his wife emma about and wanted it to be
true and there's a part of him that
believes that this obsession killed
renera's mother the doubts that he's
experiencing are interesting it's not so
much about what other people want or the
council of 101 or his preferring to have
a male because he thinks it might be
better for the realm he named her
because he was looking for a way out of
the abyss of regret and was hoping that
doing that would begin to set things
right but now he has this other problem
because she's not all that interested in
behaving how he'd like he says what if i
was wrong and then they get interrupted
by the horn for the hunt this is a bit
of insight we never had from the book it
was never really clear if he
reconsidered his decision and i suppose
this shows that it wasn't really that
important because what stands out is
that he's telling alison this he's
inadvertently planting a seed in her
which could be important because as
we'll see later there's going to be a
lot of pressure on her to try to get him
away from rinera being the heir and
making it aegon when the hunting party
make their way into the woods he learns
that it wasn't the white heart that they
were tracking it is a giant deer though
and the whole process of the hunt in
quotes is something dogs chase the
animal down so that people who work for
him can capture it and hold it in place
so that the king can then walk up and
stab it in the heart of course he misses
on the first try so there's a lot of
pain and suffering involved and all of
this amounts to an unsubtle way of
pointing that out if the king makes a
mistake if he finds himself a little off
mark then there will be pain and
suffering after that we see the white
heart approach renera who's covered in
blood it just gives her a look and then
runs away kristin pulls out his sword
and she tells him to stop but i'm not
sure what he thought he was going to be
able to do there they come back into
camp her covered with blood cold
dragging the carcass of the boar and you
see that harwin strong gives her a look
and smile while everyone else just sort
of stares i guess on some level they've
come to expect the unexpected when it
comes to the princess back in king's
landing otto talks to his daughter in
her chambers highlighting how successful
the hunt was to show how all the lords
all the men that were there are primed
for aegon to become king what mother
wouldn't want that he paints the picture
that even though no one can compel
viserys to change his choice of air
there will be problems if he doesn't
aegon is the firstborn son and to deny
him the throne would be to assail the
laws of gods and men and while that's a
little dramatic as a man of court he
knows that this is something that he can
work with he says the road ahead is
uncertain but the end is clear aegon
will be king and he tells her she must
guide viserys towards reason because
he'll never find it on his own and it's
an interesting comparison with both of
these fathers and their daughters they
both see them as pawns to their own ends
on some level and that leads them to
overlook and underestimate who they are
she goes to see the king in his chambers
you see that he lost the fingers that he
was using the maggots to treat in the
last episode which is something that
happened in the book but not until a
little bit later she tries to bring up
the succession but he talks about things
not working out with jason lannister and
renera this was meant to be another out
for him and his frustrations marry her
off just as she'll say later and of
course it didn't work out then she sees
a letter from the sea snake's brother so
in the end she talks him into sending
aid to his brother because it's the
right thing to do rhaenyra gets wind of
that as he's sending a messenger to the
stepstones they have some words with her
asking if damon sent for help he'd
rather die than do that but the king is
trying to see that that doesn't happen
he asks if she thinks he made the wrong
choice and she says it doesn't matter
because as it's been shown no one really
is concerned with what she thinks they
get into it again about him trying to
marry her off and we see their
contrasting points of view his first
arranged marriage worked out and he fell
in love with her mother so on that end
he knows what she's going through but
she points out that if they only married
for advantage then he wouldn't have
picked allison he would have married the
12 year old and left her best friend
alone now she's starting to see what
everyone else is seeing that they're
going to replace her and she sees this
as him trying to marry her off while he
can still get something out of the deal
he counters that this is her way to
strengthen her own claim multiply secure
her own line of succession and then he
does something somewhat surprising he
swears to her on her mother's memory
that she will not be supplanted and this
may have even surprised him because he
thinks about what he said and what he
promised as she walks out the door so
the episode opened with a shot of these
embers falling and the banner of house
valerian burning and we saw a ship on
fire with all these men on the ground
removing the cargo you also saw the crab
feeder stake a man who says that house
valerian is coming for him and as he's
walking away damon arrives on caraxies
causing the crab feeders men to flee the
scene the man who was being staked was
elated that someone was coming to save
him but then karaxis crushed him with
his foot when he landed here you see
that there are limits to the power that
comes with having a dragon karaxis burns
a couple of the fleeing men but you
notice that many more of them retreat
into the caves where they are shielded
and safe from his fire damon tries to
call him out he ignores him and then his
archers start to unload on him to where
he has to leave later when we revisit
them we get the idea that this isn't a
problem that they can solve with just
dragons their opponents can just run
into these caves you get the sense that
doing this for years now has gotten old
and you see that there's low morale and
even some dissent from cordless brother
who blames damon for their problems
there's really no reason for the crab
peter's men to leave the caves and
corliss's son lenore has a plan to bait
them by sending someone to their
doorstep he says it should be daemon and
then we see him arrive on karaxis at the
same time while he's skulking in front
of the men the messenger viscera scent
shows up he reads that his brother is
sending help and then almost beats the
messenger to death just to remind you
that he's not a great guy
then you see that this all motivates
them to put their plan in motion and he
rows himself ashore alone he crosses the
battlefield and plants a white flag of
surrender the crab feeder comes out with
his mask on and his grayscale and
watches him offer up dark sister from a
safe distance he kneels and hands it
over to one of the soldiers and then
pulls out his dagger and makes a charge
across the field the archers unload but
miss everyone starts to chase him and
then eventually he gets cornered we
understand that this is part of their
plan and the crab feeder just sort of
stands there and watches out for dragons
the whole thing is pretty exciting it's
exhilarating to watch him run across the
field there's a couple of things that
seem weird for instance the entire army
rush out just to try to stop this one
person and that the crab feeder is
cautious but he doesn't keep his army
close eventually that'll be their demise
because the sea snake and his ground
troops show up for a showdown and then
lanor attacks with sea smoke and saves
damon's ass he then runs into the cave
after the crab feeder and comes out with
half of his body and in his blood
covered look the episode ends with the
idea that they have just solved their
stepstones problem
i found watching this third episode to
be a somewhat frustrating experience but
that's really the point these are
frustrating people doing frustrating
things and i loved how the big set piece
of damon being brave and dynamic and
showcasing his badassery was all related
to a situation that never really had to
happen the stepstones are an important
trade route and what was happening there
would have had a negative effect on the
realm in that way but the actual war was
more about corliss acting to secure his
position as the richest man in westeros
and damon having a way to make himself
feel relevant notice how that's
reflected in so much of what the rest of
the characters are doing throughout
second of his name and while the
conquest of the stepstones isn't that
important the battle and the fact that
damon survived what was practically a
suicide mission is especially in a time
of relative peace in the kingdom a story
like that is what makes legends plus it
reinforces him in doing whatever he
wants going forward and gives him combat
experience to build on i'm guessing his
charge and the dragons will be what
scratches that game of thrones itch for
people but i found drunk vicerous and
scheming ass auto to be the standout
performances of the episode what's
really bothering you is that you weren't
born a dreamer like aegon the conqueror
i guess that tracks patty considine
really showed up to deliver the line
about dragons to jason lannister it
really underlines how solid their
position is because of that connection
they have to these natural wrecking
machines and they haven't given rise
offense a lot to do yet but i thought he
shined in his trying to worm his way in
there to put his grandson on the throne
all while having his big brother show up
to quietly remind him of his place in
their family plus you can't miss their
underestimating of their daughters and
it's interesting to watch the two young
women each discover where their power is
in this messed up situation they found
themselves in alison seems to be very
perceptive she seems to know how to talk
to her husband and she hasn't jumped
immediately on board with the idea of
taking away raniera's place so that her
own son can prosper and just to connect
the dots that was corliss's son at the
step zones who lionel strong suggested
for the king to match up with renera you
see that he is a dragon rider the plan
he came up with was pretty sharp it
worked and i suppose based on what we
know about him at this point it seems
like she could do worse i think what
stands out again this week that is
beyond the costumes the set design and
the performances which are really the
foundation that this is all built on
what stands out again is how intentional
everything is without spoiling anything
i'll just say that there were a ton of
seeds planted in this episode and that
it all leads me to believe that even
though these characters are annoying in
their own ways that it should be
entertaining as hell to watch as things
develop the character stuff all serves
to put a finer point on who these people
are and you'll want to pay attention to
what they tell you about themselves and
remember what they said at the beginning
of the series the only thing that could
bring the house of the dragon down is
itself and i think that's a great place
to leave things let me know in the
comments what you thought about the
episode and how things are taking shape
how are the different characters hitting
and if you haven't read the book where
do you think things are heading and if
you have read it what do you think about
all the additional insight that we're
getting about these characters
motivations if you want to talk book
spoilers that's fine just please mark
them so that they won't spoil people who
haven't read ahead please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon